Ci sono persone che riescono a fare
della loro passione un lavoro.
Altre,
che riescono a vivere il loro lavoro
con passione.
E poi ci sono persone
che semplicemente hanno
una passione
e un lavoro.
E sembra che queste due cose
non si tocchino mai,
non si incrocino.
Sembra.
Ma che cosa potrebbe accadere,
se invece,
questi due mondi si incrociassero,
si contaminassero,
consapevolmente.
Io ho passato lunghi periodi
della mia vita
nell'aria umida delle piscine.
Penserete che magari
la mia passione sia il nuoto.
Io ho paura persino dell'acqua alta.
In realtà, accompagnavo mia figlia
agli allenamenti e alle gare
di nuoto sincronizzato
e, nelle lunghe attese, leggevo.
Questa, sì, una mia grande passione.
Nel 2012 mi capitò di leggere
l'intervista a Christine Lagarde.
L'aveva rilasciata al settimanale Stern
perché da poco
era stata nominata
prima donna
a capo del Fondo Monetario Internazionale.
Donna elegante, di charme,
avvocato d'affari,
già ministro dell'economia in Francia,
madre di due figli, sportiva.
Una di quelle donne
che, già mentre leggi, ti chiedi:
"Ma come fa a far tutto?
Come fa a reggere certe pressioni?"
E poi, nell'intervista,
una frase rivelatrice.
Per lei, medaglia di bronzo
ai campionati nazionali in Francia
di nuoto sincronizzato
nel '73
il nuoto sincronizzato
era stato fondamentale,
le aveva insegnato
capacità di resistenza
e tenuta.
"Quando sei sotto pressione,
ti controlli, stringi i denti e sorridi".
Mi avevano colpito quelle parole.
Io conoscevo il nuoto sincronizzato
per via di mia figlia
e conosco il lavoro nelle organizzazioni.
Fu facile per me trovare
una connessione tra alcuni aspetti
della pratica del nuoto sincronizzato
e alcuni aspetti del mondo del lavoro,
per esempio la capacità
di spezzare un grande macro-obiettivo
in tanti piccoli step
da allenare con tenacia.
La capacità di rispecchiarsi
per trovare la sincronia con la squadra,
la capacità di tenere
il feedback dell'istruttore.
Insomma, è da lì che ho cominciato
a trovare sempre più connessioni
tra il mondo del lavoro
e le attività extra-lavorative,
le passioni che guidano
le nostre vite ogni giorno.
E questo è quello che vi racconterò oggi.
Che cosa potrebbe accadere
quando scegliamo consapevolmente
di portare le nostre passioni
all'interno
del mondo del lavoro.
Cosa possono avere in comune
con Christine Lagarde i fratelli Wright,
considerati gli inventori del volo,
e Art Fry,
da tutti ritenuto l'inventore dei post-it?
Beh, entrambi
hanno trovato
l'idea distintiva per l'attività lavorativa
che stavano seguendo
a partire
da una loro passione personale.
Per i fratelli Wright
fu l'osservazione della natura.
Loro, amanti della vita all'aria aperta,
si trovarono ad osservare il volo
dei grifoni, una sorta di avvoltoi
che vivono in Nord America,
e fu grazie a questo
che scoprirono in che modo
far virare l'aereo:
avrebbero dovuto creare
un meccanismo
in grado di fare inclinare
di lato il velivolo,
esattamente come, di lato,
s'inclinano gli uccelli in volo.
Per Art Fry invece fu cruciale
la sua passione per il canto
nel coro della chiesa.
Lui lavorava alla 3M e un suo collega,
già diversi anni prima,
alla ricerca di un adesivo
molto più potente,
aveva scoperto per caso
l'adesivo dei post-it.
Ma né lui, né la 3M
trovarono un'applicazione.
Finché, 6 anni dopo, nel '74,
mentre cantava nel coro della chiesa,
il nostro Art Fry,
ebbe l'idea che quei post-it
sarebbero stati dei fantastici segnalibro
nel libro degli inni, appunto.
Ecco, Christine Lagarde,
i fratelli Wright, Art Fry.
Tre esempi
di come una passione personale
possa fare la differenza
in termini di approccio al lavoro,
anche in termini di creatività,
di risoluzione dei problemi.
Tre esempi di come la passione personale
faccia la differenza
anche al lavoro.
Vediamo qualche esempio
più vicino a noi.
Quello che vedete
è un post recente di Linus,
dj e grande appassionato di corsa,
che dice:
"La corsa mi ha insegnato
a non avere paura di niente.
Quando sono in difficoltà al lavoro
mi basta ricordarmi che sono maratoneta
per sentirmi più forte".
E poi ancora, Bebe Vio,
la nostra atleta paralimpica
nel suo famoso selfie con Obama,
un selfie ottenuto
in barba a qualunque protocollo,
che durante le cene di stato
non solo impedisce di fare selfie
con il Presidente,
ma addirittura di avvicinarsi a lui.
Bene, Bebe Vio ha raccontato,
qualche settimana fa,
a "Che tempo che fa",
in che modo ha ottenuto questo selfie.
Lei ha detto:
"Ho fatto come nella scherma.
Ho guardato dritto al bersaglio,
che era Obama,
disinteressandomi
di ciò che avveniva intorno",
per esempio delle decine
di finti camerieri,
in realtà agenti segreti,
che cercavano di sbarrarle il passo.
"Ho fatto come nella scherma",
ha detto Bebe Vio,
perché lei ne era consapevole.
Ma, allora,
quello che andiamo raccontando
è una storia che vale solo
per le persone di successo?
Per quelli che ce l'hanno fatta?
E che magari ripercorrono
il loro successo
connettendo causa ed effetto?
No, non è una storia per VIP,
quella che voglio raccontarvi.
Io non sono una ricercatrice,
ma quando ho cominciato a interessarmi
di queste connessioni
e di questi incroci,
ho voluto condurre un'indagine.
Ho iniziato delle persone
più vicine a me, dai miei colleghi,
per poi passare
a fare la stessa domanda,
e cioè se ci fossero
delle connessioni tra la passione
extra lavorativa e il mondo del lavoro,
a decine e poi centinaia
di persone diverse,
appartenenti a gruppi sportivi,
club di animazione culturale,
centri di teatro amatoriale.
Insomma, persone con passioni diverse,
che naturalmente fanno lavori diversi.
Ne è venuta fuori una risposta
quasi unanime
e cioè di quanto sia efficace
cercare di usare consapevolmente
quelle capacità che alleniamo,
dando vita alle nostre passioni,
per poi sfruttarle al nostro lavoro.
Vediamo qualche esempio.
Quelle che vedete
sono le prove di volo di Cinzia,
appassionata di parapendio
e naturalmente
professionista in un'azienda.
Che cosa si porta Cinzia del parapendio,
in azienda?
Beh, per esempio la pazienza
nella gestione delle attese,
che, se nel parapendio
sono quelle del vento giusto,
in azienda spesso sono quelle
della decisione che ti fa andare avanti.
Che cos'altro si porta?
Cinzia racconta ad esempio del rispetto
e della fiducia
nelle competenze diverse degli altri,
nella capacità di relazionarsi
con persone molto diverse da lei
perché hanno, insieme,
un obiettivo comune.
Poi ancora la capacità di non prendere
un rimprovero sul personale.
Rispetto,
fiducia, feedback.
Cose che fanno parte della sua passione
e della sua vita al lavoro.
E poi Valerie,
appassionata attrice di teatro
e anche grande professionista,
che dice:
"Il teatro è improvvisazione e ascolto".
Ascolto,
perché tu puoi entrare in battuta
solo quando l'altro ti dà l'assist.
È improvvisazione,
perché devi intervenire
quando ti rendi conto
che l'altro non ce la fa.
Ora pensate, dice Valerie, in quanti casi
riesco a usare l'improvvisazione
e l'ascolto
al lavoro.
Certo, c'è qualcuno che invece
questa connessione non la trova.
Sergio, ad esempio, aveva risposto
che, secondo lui,
la preparazione fisica e mentale
che lo sport gli dona
non hanno attinenza con il suo lavoro.
Lui dice: "Li ho sempre visti
come due mondi distinti".
Ecco,
"Li ho sempre visti come
due mondi distinti".
È mancanza di connessione
o è mancanza di consapevolezza?
In ogni caso,
ciò che mi ha colpito di più
delle tante risposte
che arrivavano alla mia domanda,
spesso era,
che qualcuno mi scrivesse:
"Non ci avevo mai fatto caso,
però adesso che me l'hai chiesto
la domanda mi ha stimolato la ricerca
di questa connessione
e vado apposta a pescare
nelle capacità che alleno
nella mia passione extra-lavorativa
per portarmela anche al lavoro.
E questo funziona.
Funziona, perché lo dicono
anche i neuroscienziati,
che la motivazione parte dall'interno,
parte dalla nostra volontà
di migliorare noi stessi
e il mondo che ci circonda.
Perché noi abbiamo il desiderio istintivo
di dirigere le nostre vite con autonomia
e fare qualcosa di significativo.
E funziona,
se riusciamo a incrociare
queste competenze
e ad allacciare nuove connessioni.
Noi alla fine
tutto questo lo abbiamo chiamato
"matching skills",
perché a volte,
dare un nome a un fenomeno
aiuta ad identificarlo, a focalizzarlo.
"Matching skills",
capacità che si combinano,
capacità che si intrecciano.
Ma perché
dovremmo impegnarci
in questo intreccio?
Perché dovremmo impegnarci
in questa combinazione di capacità?
Perché l'essere umano
evolve per aggiunte,
e non per sostituzioni,
perché non possiamo vivere
due mondi distinti e separati
senza che entrambi perdano qualcosa.
Perché se da piccolo
mi piaceva la pasta al sugo
e adesso voglio solo il sushi,
io non mi sono evoluto.
Ho solo perso qualcosa.
Il punto è riuscire ad amare
entrambe le cose,
e fare in modo che queste
si arricchiscano l'una con l'altra.
Perché impegnarci in questa
combinazione di skills?
Perché l'armonia
è un luogo da esplorare.
Ed è lì che risiede l'equilibrio,
nel sentirci un intero
e non una serie di frammenti
che, in affanno,
passano dall'una all'altra vita,
da quella personale
a quella professionale,
dal piacere della passione
al dovere del lavoro.
L'essere umano da sempre
è in cerca sia del pane,
che delle rose.
È stato provato che gli esseri umani
primitivi, i nostri antenati,
uscivano dalle caverne,
al sorgere del sole,
rischiando la vita contro animali
ferocissimi per procurarsi il cibo.
Ma è stato provato che uscivano
al sorgere del sole dalle caverne,
rischiando la vita,
anche per procurarsi
coralli per fare le collane.
Rischiavano la vita per il pane
e rischiavano la vita, allo stesso modo,
per le rose.
E allora è nel destino degli esseri
umani
vivere e lavorare meglio se entrambi
i bisogni sono stimolati e soddisfatti.
Perché noi siamo un intero,
che si arricchisce nella pienezza,
purché ne siamo consapevoli.
E allora vi chiedo,
a questo punto,
ci state già pensando?
Qual è la vostra passione?
Cos'è che sapete fare bene,
fuori dal lavoro,
che potreste portarvi al lavoro?
Avete già la vostra risposta?
Vi sentite forse
di non avere sufficienti interessi
o attività extra-lavorative?
Vi voglio rassicurare.
È una domanda che mi sono posta anch'io
e mi sono chiesta,
non essendo una donna, né sportiva,
né con particolari talenti artistici,
quale fosse la mia passione distintiva.
E poi l'ho individuata.
Io adoro
chiacchierare.
Sì, sì proprio chiacchierare,
parlare, conversare.
È un retaggio genetico.
Mio nonno, Francin, contadino abruzzese
che ha attraversato
l'intero secolo scorso, nascendo
agli inizi del secolo e morendo nel 2001,
era uno storyteller naturale,
il cantore delle storie di famiglia,
talmente curioso e appassionato
della "parlata con le persone",
come diceva lui,
che spesso le apostrofava
anche se erano sconosciute.
Tipicamente con una frase
che suonava più o meno così,
in dialetto abruzzese:
"Tu me pai 'na faccia conosciuta
ma ci lu fij?"
Scusate ma portare una frase
in dialetto abruzzese a Trento
mi sembrava doveroso.
Beh, di fatto la frase significa, appunto:
"Ma, tu, mi sembra di conoscerti.
A quale famiglia appartieni?
Di quale ceppo fai parte?"
Ma era una scusa,
una scusa per parlare.
Ok, allora
una passione ereditata,
che arriva da lontano.
Ma che cosa ne ho fatto
consapevolmente, al lavoro,
di questa passione?
Qualche anno fa mi hanno chiesto
di cambiare lavoro
e di passare a occuparmi
di comunicazione interna.
È una scelta che ho fatto di testa,
però dovevo metterci
anche un po' di pancia,
e quindi
ho cercato
un luogo e una teoria
su cui fondare la nuova funzione.
Potevo sceglierne tante,
ne ho scelta una,
che è quella della facilitazione,
della progettazione
partecipata,
che si fonda, di fatto,
su una convinzione fondamentale,
e cioè che le organizzazioni,
le aziende,
siano reti di conversazioni
informali e generative.
Ed è proprio sull'onda
di questa convinzione
che nel 2012, per la prima volta,
in un'azienda italiana,
ho organizzato un World Café.
Che cos'è un World Café?
Lo chiamano
"Format di tecnologia sociale"
ma, in sostanza,
si tratta di riunire attorno a dei tavoli
delle persone che conversano
su un tema che sta loro a cuore.
E l'idea è che,
poiché le idee più forti, più efficaci,
non sono quelle
che si discutono in riunione,
ma quelle che ci vengono
alla macchinetta del caffè,
che cosa può succedere se noi
sfruttiamo quell'informalità e riuniamo
appositamente in maniera guidata
queste persone a parlare del tema
che sta loro a cuore?
Che si generano, insieme,
idee molto più innovative.
Una passione,
quella della conversazione,
che, nel World Café,
si dice che muova il mondo.
Di sicuro ha mosso me,
perché sono arrivata fino a Roma,
fino al CNR,
al Consiglio Nazionale delle Ricerche,
a parlare di world café
e naturalmente non ci sono andata da sola,
perché per parlare di conversazioni,
come minimo bisognava essere in due.
E quindi ci siamo andate in due
al CNR, a Roma.
Dunque,
parlare, conversare,
potere della consapevolezza,
non solo della conversazione.
Potere della passione,
che, a me, ha fatto arrivare fino a qui,
fino a TEDx, a Trento.
E voi?
Fin dove vi farà volare
la vostra passione?
Grazie.
(Applausi)